wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
also sie wollen sich auf eine stelle
bewerben
was ist richtig wo in einem fast food
restaurant
ok papa ist eigentlich arzt aber muss
noch eine sprachprüfung bestehen damit
er in deutschland arbeiten darf selber
was denn das geht niemanden etwas an
lisa mir helfen papa also sie müssen
zuerst dort anrufen und danach gibt es
noch ein persönliches gespräch richtig
richtig gut stand zuerst der anruf was
würden sie sagen guten tag hier spricht
die branche ich rufe an weil ich mich
bei ihnen bewerben möchte auf welcher
arbeitsstelle restaurants mitarbeiter ok
fragen sie nach einen termin für ein
bewerbungsgespräch
ich möchte wissen ob ich einen termin
für ein gespräch haben kann
lieber können sie mir sagen wie ich
einen termin für ein bewerbungsgespräch
bekommen
das klingt höflicher ok soll ich noch
meine qualifikationen sagen
nur wenn man sie danach fragt ansonsten
ist das ein thema für das
bewerbungsgespräch
dafür müssen uns auch noch vorbereiten
kennst du zufällig jemanden der weiß wie
bewerbungsgespräche ablaufen
vielleicht kenne ich sogar einen
geschäftsführer der häufig
bewerbungsgespräche führen
[Musik]